we've got some um breaking news from the
transport secretary grant shatson
let's bring in our correspondence joe
pike who's in westminster for us um this
evening joe
what more do we know well this is the
latest news on quarantined on two week
quarantines people arriving in the uk
from different countries of course
those safe lists of countries that are
on the list have changed you'll see this
tweet from
grant shap saying data shows we need to
remove the czech republic
jamaica and switzerland from our list of
coronavirus travel corridors to keep
infection rates down
if you arrive in the uk after four in
the morning on saturday from these
destinations
you will need to self-isolate for 14
days now he goes on to say
data shows we could also add cuba to
those countries
included in travel corridors so you
won't need to
uh suffice it for 14 days if you're
arriving from cuba as with all air
bridge countries
be aware that things can and do
sometimes change quickly
only travel if you are content
unexpectedly quarantined for 14 days on
return
as of course uh the transport secretary
grant chaps had to do after
uh taking a holiday so i think the key
headline there the czech republic
switzerland and jamaica are now
destinations where if you go to them
you'll have to quarantine
for two weeks for uh 14 days
of course we are likely to hear more
updates
in in the next seven days as to other
countries that could be added
to the list there certainly had been
speculation
that turkey and greece would possibly be
added
which clearly for uh those traveling or
in those traveling tour in those
countries would be
uh problematic but of course those have
not been included so
positive news for people who are
currently
holidaying or want to holiday in turkey
or greece but
less good news for people wanting to
travel to the czech republic switzerland
and jamaica as gamal the department for
transport update
their lists of travel corridors and
locations where you'll have to do a
two-week warranty